what's that
no no I wouldn't know a cop I made sure
all my photos are originals didn't
completely I don't have a double if
anything
- ha
I think this is like palliative it's
like college so we don't have to give
him 15 minutes then we do we go to the
stick
and you want to go asking if we need a
second photographer to cover the four
o'clock event
[Music]
subsequently
Roscoe
is that still for the briefing resent
for the fourth weapon
you were just crafting
hello everyone this afternoon President
Trump will deliver remarks on rolling
back regulations to help all Americans
deregulation has been a top priority of
this president the president reversed
the disastrous over-regulation of the
obama-biden administration under
President Trump seven deregulatory
actions have been taken for every one
new regulation this amounted to fifty
billion dollars in regulatory cost
savings and it is important to note that
this deregulate deregulation agenda
lowers the cost for every American the
cost of these burdensome regulations
fall disproportionately and benefit
disproportionately lower-income
Americans
so this president took action to roll
back the burdensome regulations that
harm low-income communities and make
sure that these lower-income Americans
are taken care of for example the
president's deregulatory agenda will
boost household and income by $3,100
annually
thanks to president Trump's rolling back
of the obama-biden era cafe standards
family families will have access to
cheaper cars the president's health care
deregulation will also save patients
nearly 10 percent on prescription drug
costs these real wins for the American
people will disappear with a
re-regulation agenda which is why
President Trump will continue to pursue
his historic deregulation activity on
another note we saw encouraging news
yesterday on vaccines moderna vaccine
candidate is showing promising signs it
produced a positive neutral immune
response among the 45 participants in
this study this is comparable to what we
see and recovered patients and the
bottom line is that so far we are seeing
exactly what you would hope to see in a
vaccine i their expected the moderna
vaccine in particular is expected to
reach phase 3 by late July with 30,000
participants and finally on the
therapeutics front I just want to note a
very encouraging Regeneron contract a
450 million dollar contract for
monoclonal antibody cocktail this is a
bio engineered version of convalescent
plasma
it one of the several therapeutics
available to treat Ovid can be used for
prophylaxis and treatment and they say
they could have up to seventy to 300,000
dose of vials of this by the end of the
summer or early fall so operation
warp-speed continues we continue to see
encouraging news on the therapeutics
front and with that I will take your
questions yes
Thank You Kara Maryland governor Larry
Hogan said today that President Trump
has left states to fend for themselves
during this pandemic he accused the
president of not listening to medical
experts that is quite the takedown
coming from a Republican gun yeah it's
really striking on his comments
especially when you compare them to his
past comment this is revisionist history
by Governor Hogan and it stands in stark
contrast to what he said on March 19th
where he praised the great communication
that the president has had with
governor's on March 19th he also said
thank you there's been tremendous
cooperation and what is so striking to
me about reading that op-ed is Governor
Hogan begins with this dramatic April
18th scene where South Korea delivered
tests but just the day prior he said
something entirely different he in fact
thanked the president for the progress
we've seen in federal and state
coordination in recent weeks and went on
to praise testing capabilities he said
with regard to some of the top needs of
states including ventilators and testing
capabilities so 24 hours before this
dramatic opening scene of his op-ed he
literally was praising the President of
the United States for delivering on
testing how do you explain the president
trumpet is trailing his opponent by
double digits both nationally and in
battleground states with majorities
disapproving of his handling of race
relations and the provirus that would be
a question for the campaign when it
comes to campaign polling but what I
would say is we believe this president
has great approval on this country his
historic ko video response speaks for
itself with delivering on ventilators
and testing leading the world and the
amount of testing we've provided
therapeutics the 13 vaccine candidates
the moderna example that I pointed out
to you this president's response has
been historic and we believe his support
in this country reflects that but with
pertaining to battleground pulling or
campaign related polling I'd refer you
there
yes Kelly we've seen that president hold
a range of public events this week but
none of the presidents routinely focused
on the coronavirus I think we'll be
hearing more about what we're doing in
the coming week he's hard at work we
talk about kovat every day from this
podium the task force is hard at work
and I'm glad you asked about covin in
particular because I just want to read
through some of the things that we are
doing which i think is most most
important than what we're saying is what
we're doing and the White House has
engaged and traveled dr. Burks I'm to
Louisiana Mississippi Alabama Georgia
and South Carolina I spoke with dr.
Burks this morning she's in Georgia
today heading to South Carolina tomorrow
HHS has deployed 19 teams across the
country we identify not where we see
mbers but pre that we identify where we
might see an emergence and we send teams
there to address it in advance so we're
proactive the dr. Burke's routinely
sends real-time data to governor's she
gives them governors reports on REM Desa
vir we've surged it to Texas Florida
California Arizona 65,000 vials went to
these four states and we're also a
surging testing site so we're doing
stuff each and every day
clearly surely you'd agree this is the
biggest challenge facing the public
right now why aren't we seeing it as the
president's biggest public priority the
president's focusing on a lot look the
president just yesterday held a big
press conference if you will or in a
veil in the Oval Office about ms-13
kovat is something that we're focused on
it is a top priority of this
administration it's why the task force
meets it's why I mentioned to you are
taking all those steps but there are
other things the president has to focus
on namely Democrat cities not
controlling their streets namely the
mayor of Chicago people dying in her in
our on the streets of her city every
weekend and the president sent her a
letter saying you must secure your city
the president's involved an operation
legend in honor of legend Tala Faro a
young man who lost his life sending
federal assistance to st. Louis and a
city that has asked for our help and
he's shown up the president's focused on
ms-13 who tragically maimed and killed
those two young little girls and he's
held their killer accountable the leader
of that ring so the president's focused
Sanko but it's top priority he's focused
on the violence
the streets he's doing a lot of things
at once and that's the great thing about
the Trump administration but what's the
last time he attended a taskforce
briefing the president is briefed on
coronavirus each and every day yes
darling thank you
does the White House agree that it's not
helpful for people to wait 7 days or
longer to get the results of their
Khurana pirates tests and it's the White
House going to do anything to try to
shorten those wait times so that people
can get their result sooner so we've
done more than any country in the world
on testing there's no doubt about that
42 million tests the country with the
next highest number is India at 12
million there are various different
types of tests in this country some take
longer to process than others but we
have surged testing to the States we
encourage them to use it to their best
ability and to process those tests as
quickly as possible
testing is the administration doing
anything specifically to make all the
tests out there returned clicker results
because you know a lot of health experts
are worried that when people have to
wait seven days or longer there they're
out you know spreading the disease
unknowingly so as I noted there are
several different types of tests there's
the Abbott rapid response test there are
other tests that take longer dr. Burks
and admirals wahhhh are constantly out
there advising on testing and how to
process these tests ultimately we can
give the states the supplies that
they've got to use them and the best way
possible to get results as quickly as
possible but rest assured our teams
fully engaged from Admiral's law to dr.
Burks and others and admirals wha shared
with me
we have 552 sites testing in America in
48 states and the District of Columbia
65% of these sites are located in
counties with moderate to high social
vulnerability and 201 additional sites
we'll be going live this week and that's
on top of the 1,300 federally qualified
health centers that are out there
testing as well and the commercial
testing sites at CES
in an interview with CBS News President
Trump said more white people are killed
as an answer to why black people are
still being killed by police officers
but by population percentages black
people are about three times more likely
than white people to die in a police
encounter if the president won't even
acknowledge that
how can he fix the problem the president
has routinely acknowledged and expressed
the absolute atrocity of the case of
George Floyd and his heart goes out to
that family still he was noting a fact
that there were when you look at unarmed
killings with police interactions in
this country that you had nine unarmed
black individuals who were fatally shot
in 19 unarmed white individuals that's
down from 38 and 32 respectively in 2015
so the numbers have actually come down
since the Obama administration he was
making that point but one point he wants
to strongly make is this that black men
and women who die of homicide they are
likely to die of homicide at eight times
greater than that of white individuals
and Hispanics combined that that's the
rate combined so that's an extraordinary
thing that we want to look at I've
listed for you the names of these kids
who have died across this country it is
unacceptable and under this president
he'll take action in the derelict mayor
of Chicago should step up and ask for
federal help because she's doing a very
poor job at securing her streets
yes we're dying at the hands of police
is the president considering travel fans
party to enter the US and is concerned
about escalation of tension so I have no
announcements on that front but rest
assured we keep every option on the
table with regard to China he's not
ruled out any options with regard to
China thanks Kelly
does the White House have a reaction to
the passing of Twitter last night and
you have any broader concerns or does
the president have any broader concerns
about using that platform to issue not
only his own opinions but official
policy pronouncements given its apparent
vulnerability to happen yeah so I spoke
with dance Covino before coming out here
my team did and Dan has been in and his
team and digital have been in constant
contact with Twitter over the last 18
hours to keep Twitter secure the
president's Twitter feed the president
will remain on Twitter but his account
was secured and not jeopardized during
these attacks okay I just want to follow
up to read this question I guess I
didn't follow the data that you were
just referring to are you saying that
the President did have data to back up
his claim that more white people are
killed by police officers than black
people yeah I've already read out that
data to you I think we followed it I did
already run out that gave it to you and
you can go back check on two quick
questions Chris congressman Steve
Watkins of Kansas has been charged with
three felonies in a voter fraud case
obviously President
in 2018 and he's repeatedly expressed
concern with voter fraud so does he have
a reaction to that I that's the first
time hearing of that I haven't spoken to
the president of it he does have very
real concerns about voter fraud and he's
mentioned several of those and there's
yet more information that there is
rampant voter fraud when you have mass
mail-in voting in 2016 as the president
has noted about one percent of absentee
ballots nationwide were thrown out and
it could be much higher this year as
many people vote by mail for the first
time that's one of the flaws with mass
mail and voting but beyond that we've
seen a number of reports out of New
Jersey have found a US Postal Service
vehicle that may have been carrying
mail-in ballots that were that was
caught on fire this truck this was a
recent also in the New Jersey Star
Ledger on June 22nd this was very
striking 500 to 700 Republicans received
ballots with all Democrat candidates
they were erroneous mail-in ballots that
had been voided and then reissued and
the slate of candidates on these ballots
was all Democrat from Joe Biden down to
dog catcher and these were supposed to
be Republican ballots those are three
recent examples and there are many more
quick second questions everybody when
the president made the initial decision
to move the Republican National
Convention
from Charlotte to Florida he said that
it was because the North Carolina
Governor was gonna shut down food and
that he was playing politics because we
didn't have a pack an indoor stadium to
fall
pasady we also said that the cost to
North Carolinians would be in according
the president now all of the jobs and
economic development the cotton the
convention would bring so all of that
money all of that time all of that cost
to jobs and economic development to
North Carolinians for the same result
because there's a convention in the
Florida what does the person I have to
say that North Carolinians president
loves the people of North Carolina
they're well aware of that the president
wanted to be able to hold his convention
which is why it was moved to
Jacksonville and for anything further
I'd refer you to the RNC yes Thank You
Kerry the president has talked about an
executive order on immigration coming
soon he's also talked about protections
for daca recipients it's been unclear
though whether those protections the
path to citizenship that the president
talked about will be included in the
executive order so it's hoping you could
clarify will the path to citizenship
protections for going to be part of the
executive order so what I would say is
this as the president announced he's
working on an executive order to
establish a merit-based immigration
system that will be the intent of the
executive order but the president has
long said that he would look for a
legislative solution on daca and he
would work with Congress to pursue that
legislative solution and one that could
include citizen citizenship along with
other strong border security and
permanent merit-based reforms so that is
something he would work with Congress on
yeah and the executive order would
pertain to the merit-based portion of
that a second question on the schools
the president the vice president talked
about some of the guy new guidelines are
new pages of documents for CDC coming
out this week is that still the plan are
those going to come out this week is
there any chance that this is being
rethought at this time so those are CDC
guidelines you're referencing so I'll
leave it I'll leave it to CDC as to when
those guidelines come out but we really
would like to see schools open as has
been clear we don't think our children
should be locked up at home with
devastating consequences when it's
perfectly safe for them to go to school
as emphasized by many medical experts so
the president is very keen on seeing
schools reopen it's the only
that's fair to America's children yes
thanks Thalia
two quick questions for you on Wednesday
the CDC director said quote if all of us
would put on a face covering now for the
next four weeks six weeks I think we
could drive this epidemic into the
ground
Admiral Joe our Jarrar has made similar
comments the CDC director called it our
quote major defense I'm wondering if the
president would consider at any point I
a nationwide mass planting well the
president has said that he would wear a
mask if he was in a place where he
couldn't be appropriately social
distanced he did wear a mask this
weekend when he visited the hospital so
he has shown that you know he'll wear a
mask and not only that that he would
wear one if he wasn't socially distance
as evidenced by his own actions we leave
it to localities to make the decisions
with regard to face coverings and the
CDC guidelines remain the same today
recommended but not required
second question for you we're saying
earlier the president is very concerned
about local officials who are not taking
actions about you know deaths in their
cities you also said he was appalled by
what happened to George Floyd in March a
26 year old black woman named Brianna
Taylor was killed while sleeping in her
home the three officers involved in that
case in Kentucky have not been arrested
or fired is the president monitoring
that case at all and does he want to see
justice for Brianna Taylor yeah well way
into that other than to say I'd refer
you to the DOJ who takes federal action
more necessary where the facts marry but
our hearts grieve for Brianna Taylor's
family
thank you I mean the question on China
resident from is the only
have stood strong against China which is
of great comfort to countries like India
with an isolation mission neighborhood
desi has a message to China on this and
has he spoken to China the country's
toughest job Thank You Lalit I did see
your question earlier and I brought it
to the president and he said I love the
people of India and I love the people of
China and I want to do everything
possible to keep the peace for the
people question 2 flows from two events
that we saw recently that we wouldn't
have seen at previous White House's the
first was the campaign meeting in the
Cabinet Room last month and then the
political speaks in the Rose Garden this
week can you talk about your
understanding of what the White House
policy is for this White House at as far
as politics is there anyplace in the
White House where you think politics is
inappropriate where do you where do you
draw the line we act in accordance with
the Hatch Act it's well established that
the President and Vice President are not
subject to the Hatch Act it says this
much in the Hatch Act it says that the
Hatch Act applies to executive branch
employees which is defined in the Hatch
Act as employee meaning any individual
other than the President and the Vice
President so realize was the fact that
the president gave a a very good
powerful speech from the Rose Garden
well you talked about earlier with
school districts but we're seeing more
school districts at least in Virginia
for example last night deciding to go
online only what does the president say
to parents out there Lord I'll go okay
mikage yeah the president has said
unmistakably that he wants schools to
open and I was just in the Oval talking
him about that and when he says open he
means open and full kids being able to
attend each and every day at their
school the science should not stand in
the way of this and as dr. Scott Atlas
said I thought this was a good quote of
course we can do it everyone else in the
Western world are pure nations are doing
it
we are the outlier here the science is
very clear on this that you know for
instance you look at the JAMA pediatric
study at 46 pediatric hospitals in North
America that said the risk of critical
illness from kovat is far less for
children than that of seasonal flu the
science is on our side here and we
encourage for localities and states to
just simply follow the science open our
schools it's very damaging to our
children there's a lack of reporting of
abuse there's mental depressions that
are not addressed suicidal ideations
that are not addressed when students are
not in school our schools are extremely
important they're essential and they
must reopen yes thanks Kaylee US Canada
UK today excuse in Russia trying to have
grown the virus research vaccine
research I was wondering if the
president has a response to Russia yes
the one thing I would say about that and
it was made it was announced earlier
today is that we worked very closely
with our allies to ensure that we would
take measures to keep that information
safe and we continue to do so we're
aware of those activities yes
I'm the CDC on the movement of data
going straight from CDC to HHS now
understanding that HHS needs access to
real-time data was there also any
concern whatsoever under girding this
decision regarding CDC's possible
manipulation of data there was some
reports coming out of Florida certain
states were coming out and saying
mid-level CDC reports were not
necessarily accurate and so was that did
that have any effect in this decision to
send data straight to HHS no the intent
for this decision and I talked
extensively today with dr. Burks with
secretary azar and with dr. Redfield
about this the intent of this is we need
to make sure that there is daily data
that is being given to dr. Burks and
others who are running point on a lot of
our actions with from des aveer and
identifying hotspots and I would point
out and I just want to explain this I
think there's been some confusion in the
press that there are two methods of data
collection the one is the national
healthcare safety network and this is a
CDC system and this is where hospitals
voluntarily report their data and about
81 percent of hospitals were reporting
their data so we don't need 81 percent
of hospitals reporting data we need 100
percent of hospitals reporting data
because it is critical that dr. Burks
and others receive the daily admissions
ICU use and PPE numbers and when you're
only getting 81 percent of hospital data
that means you've got 19 percent of
hospitals that were unaware of their
needs so what happened is we also have a
second method of using of tracking this
data and it's the teletrac ER database
and this is an HHS system and this was
initially used for purposes of provider
relief funding and we asked hospitals to
tell us about their kovat admissions so
that we could identify possible hotspots
and as it turns out this data ended up
being more complete more up-to-date with
information and so ensuring that
hospitals are reporting into this system
where we're getting more complete data
was the reason that HHS has had this
transition where they've asked hospital
to transition reporting to the tell
attractor tell a tracker system and it's
important especially with REM desapeared
distribution that we know exactly where
the needs are so we can surge them so
this access to data yes that's right so
I I did confirm that with dr. Redfield
that this is completely open source data
available to the CDC secretary azar says
we insist that they use it and no one
and dr. Redfield confirm this no one is
taking access or data away from the CDC
and that data is routinely published so
that the American people are fully
informed yes so I wanted to fall on that
briefly there's been some complaints
particularly among independent modelers
who are using the CDC data that was a
daily relied on that now those
dashboards have been taken down so I'm
wondering if the administration would
sort of commit to making the product
database a bit more available for public
the CDC database is the public data
that's been out there it'll continue to
be public it should be public and this
is all about getting more data out there
not less data and ensuring in particular
that our doctors get that daily data and
one thing that I'd also like to point
out for everyone it's just with regard
to testing we've done more than 42
million tests as I noted the second
highest number is 12 million from India
we're leading the world in testing it's
a very stark contrast and the president
mentioned this yesterday so I just
wanted to put some some additional
information out there is actually CBS
reporting that in 2009 under Obama Biden
quotes and this is CBS reporting CDC
abruptly advised States to stop testing
for h1n1 flu and stopped counting
individual cases so while this
president's surge testing under the
Obama administration they stopped
testing entirely in Ron Klain Vice
President Biden's former chief of staff
said this it is purely a fortuity that
h1n1 isn't one of the great mass
casualty events in American history
nothing to do with us doing anything
right this is former VP Biden's chief of
staff
had to do with luck contrary to that
this president led the world in testing
led the world and ventilators
redistributing ventilators for
therapeutics 13 vaccine candidates one
going into phase three clinical trial
this response has been extraordinary and
historic we didn't pause testing the
obama-biden administration did and that
was a shameful decision thank you
[Music]
you
one two